Brooklyn New York home to an
ultra-orthodox Jewish community and one
of America's largest outbreaks of
measles in nearly three decades at a
time when more people are opting out of
vaccinations for religious and
philosophical reasons today we are
declaring a public health emergency
effective immediately we cannot allow
this dangerous disease to make a
comeback here in New York City we have
to stop it now
some unvaccinated children living in
close quarters are now seriously sick we
have at least six people that I know of
that are in ICU with people in comas we
have people with pneumonia this is
terrifying people here pray eat and shop
together there are plenty of large
families that spend a lot of time
together barks if people are vaccinated
that can mean a disease like measles
spreads very quickly and in Brooklyn and
Queens it did in just five months there
were 498 cases it's brought a former
British doctor back to the spotlight
Andrew Wakefield was struck off the
medical register after his study linking
the MMR vaccine with autism was widely
discredited and condemned he's found a
new audience in the US and health
officials say he and others are
spreading propaganda and risking
people's health why did you choose that
community today I was asked to speak to
this Mid City community about the
particular problems that they face and
my concerns my scientific are genuine
scientific concerns about the safety of
this vaccine and the US authorities say
the recent outbreaks 839 cases across 23
states are caused in part by the fact
people are not getting vaccinated do you
accept that no I don't it's very very
interesting the answer is that it's not
failure to vaccinate it's failure of the
vaccine and they've run into major
problems about which they know no they
do not know what to do the reality is
all these years later there still is no
definite scientific link that has been
proven to connect the MMR vaccine with
autism is that we have been urging for
that study to be done we have been
urging since Congress first required it
in 1986 that there should be a
systematic comparison of the health
outcomes in vaccinated versus
unvaccinated children but in the absence
of that you are still okay with sharing
a message which pulls doubt on
vaccinations yes indeed that is there is
cleared and there is cleared out because
all of the assurances that were given us
were entirely wrong but doubt results in
hard decisions and life-changing
decisions they get information from both
sides and they assimilate that
information and make a decision for
themselves and that is the basis of
informed consent now the head of NHS
England says it's as irresponsible to
dissuade people from getting the vaccine
as it is to tell their children not to
look both ways as they cross the road
what do you make of that I do not tell
people have got to do I provide them
with information which is the other side
clearly of the disinformation that's
being provided by the head of the
National Health Service so utterly
ridiculous statement to make it's a far
more complex issue than that and that's
why intelligent parents around the world
are asking questions at a rally in
Albany Wakefield has some emboldened and
increasingly organized supporters they
rail against the pharmaceutical industry
and then end to religious exemptions
Heather believes her daughter Bella has
autism because of the MMR vaccine she
was diagnosed with autism at two and
even though I know she was gone much
sooner and now she's gonna be 18 like I
said and instead of getting ready for
things she deserved to be getting ready
for I have to go to court and get
guardianship to take care of her because
she cannot live a normal life she's
always gonna need somebody to support
her back in Brooklyn the vast majority
of people do vaccinate but there's
intense debate - I was not vaccinate
with measles it's been proven to cause
autism both of my kids are being
vaccinated yes are you concerned about
the measles outbreak no because we are
being vaccinated so we don't really have
to be concerned some say it's just
Outsiders trying to mislead and exploit
it is happening right now
they're aiming at the Jewish community
the Yiddish speaking community they're
aiming the same as they're aiming in
other type of minority communities so
unfortunately we are one of their
targets as well there is a hotline being
used by Jewish mothers called Akira's
her bias and it offers everything from
cooking tips to weight loss advice and
anti vaccine messages take a listen to
some of the things that are being said
this pamphlet has also been circulated
produced by a group called peach it
claims that vaccines are made from fetal
tissue and monkey cells and falsely
states that the link with autism is
undeniable Toby Ashe is part of an
Orthodox group of Jewish nurses trying
to fight misinformation a lot of the the
scientific studies that they purport
have either been discredited our
extraordinarily biased have never been
reproduced or have been retracted
so it's terrifying when somebody reads
this they actually believed that
vaccinating their children is putting
their child's life in danger and she has
this to say about Andrew Wakefield
addressing ultra-orthodox Jews Andrew
Wakefield is an example of a disgraced
doctor stripped of his license based on
a preponderance of evidence who has has
found salvation here in the United
States vaccine critics aren't confined
to one community or one ideology but
they are growing scientific consensus it
seems is still not enough for some who
did Ilitch Sky News Brooklyn New York